[Música]
Colombia de El Salvador entraron por
primera vez a la lista de crisis
humanitarias a más desatendidas del
mundo una relación de 10 países que
encabeza burkina faso y que incluye
también a Venezuela vamos a conversar
sobre la lista enfocados en estos países
con David García él es gerente de
incidencia de nrc en Colombia Ecuador y
Panamá Muchísimas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros David
Ángela Muy buenos días a usted y a su
audiencia la insuficiencia de fondos Es
la principal razón de la inclusión de
Colombia y del Salvador Venezuela se
mantiene ahí por sus años de crisis
Estos son países de origen y tránsito de
grandes rutas de migración de
indocumentados hacia el norte Cuál es la
responsabilidad de Estados Unidos en
esta crisis
Ángela Mire las crisis en los diferentes
países de la región como consecuencia de
la violencia los desbordamientos de los
ríos o las sequías No son nuevos la
diferencia es que Oye más personas con
necesidades humanitarias y tal vez menos
recursos para aliviar esa el hambre o su
sufrimiento
le voy a dar un ejemplo los donantes
humanitarios el año pasado financiaron
en Colombia 38 de cada 100 dólares para
atender las necesidades humanitarias de
aproximadamente siete millones de
personas para ponerle en contexto esos
mismos donantes financieros 87 de cada
100 dólares para atender la situación en
Ucrania en el 2022 yo nosotros creemos
como consejo noruego para refugiados que
no solamente los Estados Unidos todos
los países donantes deben hacer un
esfuerzo mayor para atender las crisis
desatendidas nuestro reporte lo que
sugiere es que la detención pues es una
opción olvidar es una opción y Esperamos
que esa opción cambie con nuestro
llamado de atención bien Colombia es una
de las de las crisis más desatendidas
ocupa el tercer lugar y los conflictos
en el país siguen desplazando a miles de
personas a las que se suman además dos
coma cinco millones de venezolanos que
han llegado a esta nación Quiero
preguntarle esto desdibuja mucho el
acuerdo de paz se ha firmado con las
guerrilla de las farguettes retrocedió
Colombia
el acuerdo de paz esté firmado y los
actuales además negociaciones de paz
creemos como consejo noruego para
refugiados que son claves pero lograr la
paz en el país No es fácil Usted sabe
que el comité Internacional de la Cruz
Roja sugiere que en el país hay siete
conflictos armados activos Eso quiere
decir que mientras que las negociaciones
se desarrollan hay niños y niñas que
huyen de reclutamiento forzado o de las
minas antipersonales o eh de los
combates que dañan a sus escuelas la
respuesta humanitaria en esos casos
sigue aliviando a esas personas y brinda
Esperanza a esos niños y niñas y por
otro lado es urgente que el gobierno
mientras
desarrollan las negociaciones llegue a
las áreas Rurales del país con sus
instituciones un puesto de salud una
escuela la defensoría del pueblo donde
hoy no hay nada es fundamental el
gobierno Debe llegar a donde estén miles
más desprotegidos en el país y esa es
una tarea que se debe cumplir lo antes
posible Además este informe explica que
Venezuela recibe comparativamente muy
poca atención y cobertura de los medios
de comunicación y de las organizaciones
respecto a otras crisis de
desplazamiento Pese a que es una de las
mayores crisis de desplazamiento que
existe en el mundo son un
aproximadamente siete millones de
venezolanos que han abandonado en
condición de vulnerabilidad de su país
podemos atribuir esto a la normalización
de la diáspora venezolana y a su
discriminación
Ángela Por una parte tiene razón pero
como pasa con todas las crisis
humanitarias en el mundo
Desafortunadamente la comunidad
internacional los mismos medios los
políticos la sociedad civil parecen
prestar mucha más atención a lo que
ocurre recientemente y dejamos las
crisis prolongadas a un lado no podemos
dejar que eso suceda bajo ninguna razón
razonamiento las necesidades
humanitarias de una persona afectada por
una crisis prolongada como la crisis
venezolana son las mismas o son
similares a las de una persona que acaba
de ser afectadas por una crisis súbita o
una crisis reciente el sufrimiento
humano es es igual y no debería haber
ninguna de crisis desatendida por eso el
llamado de nuestra organización a que
realmente
el mundo preste mayor atención a estas
crisis que están siendo desatendidas no
solamente por los donantes pero también
por la comunidad internacional por los
políticos por la sociedad civil por los
medios ya le pregunté por Colombia Ya le
pregunté por Venezuela y ahora quisiera
que habláramos del Salvador el
presidente nayib bukele ha hecho un
trabajo muy efectivo cambiando la imagen
del país y dando una nueva sensación de
seguridad A partir de su muy criticada
guerra contra las pandillas
y por eso le quiero preguntar qué hace
pensar entonces en El Salvador como una
crisis Porque es diferente lo que se nos
está vendiendo hacia el exterior
porque mire todos los todos los años los
actores humanitarios incluyendo las
agencias de Naciones Unidas y las ongs
internacionales acordamos un plan de
respuesta humanitario para atender las
necesidades de Quienes más lo necesitan
en cada país El Salvador no es la
excepción ahí existe un plan ese plan de
respuesta en El Salvador También incluye
a personas afectadas por desastres y el
cambio climático el corredor seco en El
Salvador afecta a la población y no
podemos olvidar en esta lista a quienes
tienen necesidades humanitarias ni por
la violencia ni por las sequías o las
inundaciones
además también cerca de quince mil
personas fueron retornadas desde México
y Estados Unidos el año pasado hacia el
Salvador Eso significa representa un
aumento del 70% En comparación con el
2021 muchas de estas personas necesitan
asistencia humanitaria y protección
finalmente El Salvador también es un
país de tránsito de migrantes hacia el
norte del continente
está lista de crisis desatendidas del
Consejo noruego pues representa un
esfuerzo no solamente para hacer
énfasis en las violencias que siguen
ocurriendo en El Salvador sino también
para no dejar nadie atrás sin la ayuda
que necesita Bueno y entonces usted Por
qué cree que justamente sea El Salvador
una de las crisis que cuentan con menor
financiación en el mundo el este reporte
cita que solamente se entregó el
equivalente a un 27% de la ayuda que
necesita el país Por qué pasa tan
desapercibida
Bueno hay varias razones pero la
principal razón posiblemente es que no
todos los países están haciendo lo
suficiente mire la mayoría de recursos
80 de cada 100 dólares que llega para
brindar asistencia humanitaria proceden
de los Estados Unidos
Eso quiere decir que solamente 20 de
cada 100 dólares proceden de otros
países en el mundo que pudieran mejorar
su asistencia humanitaria en el país y
otra de las principales razones es el
desconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional sobre las necesidades y la
situación de la población y yo le voy a
dar un ejemplo muy concreto en el 2022
los medios publicaron dos millones de
artículos en inglés sobre la situación
en Ucrania mientras que solo publicaron
375.000 artículos sobre las 10 crisis
más desatendidas que el consejo noruego
para refugiados cita en su listado por
eso nosotros creemos que la
responsabilidad debe ser definitivamente
de todos y de todas los donantes los
político los medios de la sociedad civil
todas las personas podemos hacer un poco
más porque les necesitan de esa ayuda
humanitaria necesitamos compartir
solidariamente la desatención pues mire
Yo le agradezco definitivamente después
de esta conversación lo que nos queda
claro es que ninguna crisis es más
importante que la otra aunque sean
algunas crisis más publicitadas que
otras es David García gerente de
incidencia de nrc en Colombia Ecuador y
Panamá gracias a usted Muchísimas
gracias Ángela que esté muy bien gracias
También a los televidentes vamos a la
pausa y ya volvemos con más de directo a
América
[Música]